بات اكثر من ثمانيه وعشرين مليون شخص في
افغانستان اي ما يقرب من ثلثي السكان
معرضنا لمخاطر المجاعه وايضا التدهور
الاقتصادي والفقر في اعقاب تصعيد حكومه
الطالبان ضد المراه وما تلاه من ادانات
دوليه واسعه كان اخرها تعليق منظمات
اغاثيه لاعمالها الامم المتحده اعلنت
ايقاف بعض برامج المساعدات بشكل مؤقت ردا
على حضر فرضته طالبان على العاملات
الافغانيات في مجال الاغاثه والمنظمات
الاجنبيه غير الحكوميه الامم المتحده حذرت
من ان العديد من الانشطه الاخرى في طريقها
للتوقف في محاوله للضغط على الحركه التي
تتخذ قرارات وصفت بالله انسانيه ضد النساء
قال منسق المساعدات بالامم المتحده
مارتنفيس ورؤساء وكالات تابعه للامم
المتحده ومنظمات اغاثه اخرى ان مشاركه
المراه في ايصال المساعدات غير قابل
للتفاوض ويجب ان تستمر داعين طالبان
للتراجع عن قرارها وتؤكد المنظمات
الاغاثيه انها لا يمكنها تجاهل القيود
التشغيليه التي تواجهها الان في افغانستان
حيث باتوا غير قادرين على اداره برامجهم
بدون موظفات